donald trump's net worth jumped an
estimated 600 million dollars since he
left office due in part to truth social
trump's stake in the new social media
app is worth an estimated 430 million
dollars alone pushing his fortune up to
three billion dollars on this year's
billionaires list
the former president announced in
october he was creating his own social
media platform through the trump media
and technology group after being banned
from twitter despite a glitchy rollout
beginning in february the app has been
downloaded more than a million times and
retail traders have at times pushed the
share price past 50 dollars a share
based on clues buried in regulatory
findings trump probably owns at least 50
percent we estimated the value of the
shares trump should eventually receive
at 10 a piece reflecting the discounted
rate that a handful of smart money
investors recently agreed to pay to jump
into the frenzy
trump media has not yet merged with the
smack that is hosting the shares on the
stock market and since the deal hasn't
gone through the former president can't
sell his presumed shares on the open
market today but there are some doubts
about whether the merger will happen at
all both the securities and exchange
commission and the financial industry
regulatory authority are looking into
the deal bottom line the spac is good
news for trump but it's not something he
should be banking on quite yet